many people thought that we would see
Loki in Avengers in game but not exactly
in the way that we did many people
thought that the god of mischief wasn't
actually dead and would make a
triumphant return in Avengers endgame
however that is not exactly what
happened
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it appears that Loki is in fact dead in
the timeline that the Avengers existent
in the earth-616 universe however when
the Avengers were going back in time it
seems like they did create an alternate
timeline with Loki getting the tesseract
and escaping leaving one of the biggest
questions about Avengers in game to be
what exactly happened with Loki did he
in fact create an alternate timeline and
what happens in that timeline that he
created if he did well luckily for us
the Russo brothers in a recent interview
have told us what exactly happens with
Loki I'll break down what the research
said in this video but first if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
at the 400,000 subscriber mark I'll be
picking three winners and each winner
will choose one item that they want from
the Marvel Legends series collection in
an interview with Business Insider the
rooster brothers talked about that scene
with Loki disappearing they said that
the Loki that we know from Avengers
infinity war is in fact dead but the
Loki from the past from 2012 is in fact
alive due to an unexpected Hulk smash
Loki ends up grabbing the tesseract and
teleports away using the space stone
seemingly creating an alternate timeline
and the Russo brothers have recently
confirmed this in the interview with
Business Insider here's what Joe Russo
had to say
Loki when he teleports away with the
space stone would create his own
timeline it gets very complicated but it
would be impossible for cap to rectify
the timeline unless he found Loki the
minute that Loki does something as
dramatic as take the space stone he
creates a branched reality Anthony Russo
goes on to say we're dealing with this
idea of multiverses and branched
realities so there are many realities so
according to the Russo brothers the Loki
from 2012 lives and even Captain America
returning all of the Infinity stones to
the point to where they were taken back
in time would not stop this alternate
reality from being created the only way
they could stop this alternate reality
from being created is if he went back in
time and actually found Loki something
that would be pretty impossible in
something that the rooster
did confirm Captain America did not do
so the Loki from 2012 officially created
a time branch and a different reality
one in which he is still very well alive
since Marvel is introducing the
multiverse into the MCU this is
something that we could get a solo movie
in itself on a different universe with
completely different events one in which
Loki is alive and since Loki is getting
his very own TV series with the Disney
Plus streaming service this alternate
timeline that Loki created is probably
something they'll explore at one point
during the show in fact according to
some rumors the show may involve Loki go
into different multiverses across time
but the Russo brothers have officially
confirmed that Loki did in fact create
an alternate timeline in Avengers in
game and Captain America returning the
stones did not race this so the Loki
from 2012 is somewhere out there alive
and well most likely causing mischief so
be sure to let me know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below and again if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway at the 400,000 subscriber
mark I will be picking three winners and
each winner will choose one item from
the Marvel Legends series collection and
of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel don't
forget to like the video and comment
down below to let me know what you think
about it and as always thank you so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]